what they're doing here is in response
to a new york law that says that if
you're
being sued for defamation you can
actually mitigate some of those
circumstances by
filing a retraction and filing a
retraction can help with punitive
damages though it won't reduce the
compensatory damages if you are sued for
defamation
we wanted to talk to you about
cancelling
culture if you will we don't want to
re-litigate
the the wait i'm being repressed
and i'm being repressed see the violence
inherent in the system
so you know what they did this because
i'm revealing all the evidence on friday
of all the election problems with these
machines and then he just goes right
back to it
can i ask our producers can we get out
of here please
i don't want to have to keep going over
this yeah they're afraid because
they should be mike hold on a second
everybody hold on a second mike
mike hold on one second and then the
epic walk-off check out my whole video
on the whole defamation suit and
subscribe or i'll see you
in court